hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be discussing what was perhaps the most
controversial twist in all of black
clover the shocking new chapter of black
clover is already being criticized and
debated by fans all over the internet
this might have been a step too far for
tabata and a lot of fans are not happy
let's put it this way osta just carried
a completely naked woman in his arms and
that is the least controversial part of
the entire chapter let's get into it if
you enjoy the black lover content here
on the channel and you want to see more
you know what to do just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you actually watch our videos regularly
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications
it is a quick little thing but it's also
a very real way of directly supporting
the channel finally this video will of
course contain black lover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned now my biggest
question from the previous chapter was
whether mkikula had really been defeated
or whether she would just find some way
to regenerate yet again like she's done
multiple times before the latest chapter
confirms right at the beginning that
megikula has in fact
been defeated at least for now not only
is her decaying world curse dissolving
but even the curse that she had placed
on loro pachika has completely
disappeared from loro's body since this
is a curse that has been affecting loto
for a very long time and it wasn't just
some temporary thing the fact that it
disappeared does signal that megicula
has been banished from this world again
i have to say for now because we can't
say for sure that megicula is actually
dead as we know she only partially
manifested into this world she was not
at her full power so her true body is
likely still somewhere deep within the
underworld if the tree of cliffhoth
isn't closed soon mkikula may still
return through the cliff off at some
point in the future personally i do
think that she will return at some point
just because of the fact that we still
haven't seen her at her full power i
would find it a bit unsatisfying if
megicula was killed before we ever got
to see her at full power since she is
such a major villain and one of the
strongest and highest ranked devils but
we'll have to wait to find out more as
loro's curse disappears she regains
consciousness and she suddenly finds
herself completely naked and being held
by asta loro understandably freaks out
and apologizes to asta for being naked
and meanwhile asta is also kind of
confused and he's like oh i haven't seen
anything don't worry sure us uh sure bro
are you sure about that anyway at the
sight of asta holding a naked loro noel
goes back into full tsundere mode and
punches asta to get him away from loro
noel then embraces loto and both her and
undine are absolutely ecstatic to see
that loro is actually okay meanwhile
noel is also super excited to see asta
but she is embarrassed at the same time
and so she continues to be an aggressive
tunde towards a confused awesome uh i
have to say this was disappointing to
see i mean i could appreciate the humor
in this situation but after all of the
character development that noel has gone
through including finally facing up to
her true feelings for asta seeing her go
back to this ditzy tsundere stuff was
not very dijobu in my opinion i hope
this won't last and that she will
confess her feelings soon but if she
does revert back to an aggressive tundra
for a longer period of time i will be
disappointed next up real reveals to
charlotte that the effects of his spell
twilight valhalla are about to run out
this is bad news for real charlotte and
gaia who were basically on life support
before the spell helped them recover
some of their strength just as loro sees
gaia and runs towards him he only has
enough energy to say to her that he's
glad she's safe before dropping to the
ground charlotte and rail also collapse
and for a moment it looks like all three
of them might die
yeah right this is black clover but it
does look like that for like a few
seconds as loro tries to use her water
recovery magic to help them heal but the
magic proves incapable of healing such
severe injuries asta is also unable to
help and loto begins to cry as she
considers the prospect of gaia charlotte
and real dying without being able to do
anything for them and yet they are in
this situation because they sacrificed
so much to help loro noel is also on the
verge of despair but that is when noct
shows up entering the room through a
shadow on the floor at first knocked is
very somber as if he had already
accepted the fact that gaia and the
others will die he says that nothing can
be done for them now and that's okay
because at least they beat one of the
strongest devils so that makes these
sacrifices worthwhile he also says that
while he would like the righteous to
always be rewarded for their good deeds
that simply isn't realistic because
reality is far more brutal and as
knocked is giving this little speech i'm
thinking okay so i guess knocked is
preparing us for a real loss that is
about to take place we are about to see
the very real consequences of fighting
an overpowered opponent like megikula
now don't get me wrong i didn't think
that charlotte or real would really die
but i thought that knocked words would
at least apply to gaia because he was
all but dead even before twilight and
valhalla kicked in i mean even gaia
himself had accepted that he was about
to die but then
knocked reveals that he brought someone
with him
mimosa mimosa enters the chat she vows
not to let anyone die and she then uses
ultimate plant magic to instantly heal
charlotte rill
and gaia as noel says that thanks to
magic reality can be turned into
whatever we want it to be a now fully
recovered gaia confesses his feelings to
an emotional lordo he tells her that he
loves her not as a queen but as a woman
loro blushes profusely everyone is just
kind of surprised that guy would confess
his feelings at a time like this
and nozella knocked are already thinking
about the next steps nozell is thinking
about the need to save yami since he is
clearly an effective captain who managed
to make his little sister much stronger
and knocked is thinking about the final
dark triad member who still has to be
defeated xenon the chapter then switches
focus to the chamber where yuno and
language are fighting xenon a short time
before megicula was defeated at a
different location xenon in his
absolutely terrifying devil form is
anxious to end this fight once and for
all yuno tells langers to buy him 3
minutes and he will end it all with the
next attack and that is how this chapter
ends
and while i am excited to see the xenon
fight i have to go back to what just
happened in the other location with
mimosa basically becoming shenron from
dragon ball z we all know the meme that
no one dies in black clover but this
chapter took that meme to a whole other
level and this has generated a lot of
controversy this could be the most
controversial chapter in black clover to
date and many fans are already talking
about it online and from what i've seen
a lot of people are very upset as for me
i'm not upset my job is talking about
anime and manga so there's no reason for
me to be mad just getting to make these
videos is freaking awesome and i love it
but i do agree that this was not a great
chapter and this could have serious
consequences for the future of the story
now just to be clear it is not true that
literally no one dies in black clover
many characters died in the past before
the series started and we saw their
deaths in flashbacks villains like
zagred have also died and some very
minor side characters have died like
those members of the golden dawn who
were killed by xena however it is true
that even somewhat important characters
in black clover who are alive when the
story started simply don't die during
this megicula fight both vanika and gaia
were on the brink of death and let's be
real neither of these characters are
characters that the story can't go on
without they are relevant characters in
this arc but the series would certainly
survive without them and yet from the
looks of it they are both still alive
but worse than that the ultimate plant
magic recovery spell that mimosa used
seems way too overpowered and unless
we're all missing something this spell
really lowers the stakes for the
showdown inside the spade kingdom not
only was mimosa able to save someone
from certain death almost instantly she
was able to do it for three people at
once and gaia was practically dead
already and yet he was seemingly fully
healed in like two seconds i mean that's
great for gaia and loro and i have huge
respect for gaia for publicly confessing
his feelings by the way take a hint noel
but this was not necessarily good for
the story as a whole if even a minor
character like gaia is going to be saved
from certain death then how are we
supposed to believe that any major
character's life will ever be in danger
how are we supposed to feel actual
tension about someone like yami or yuno
potentially dying when it seems
practically certain that no one
important is going to die in black
clover period while this doesn't upset
me personally and while i am still
enjoying the story i can definitely
understand why some people are upset and
why they feel that mimosa basically
becoming shenron is bad for the story
even though i liked certain aspects of
this chapter i have to say that this is
one of my least favorite chapters in the
whole series noel going back into
aggressive tundra mode and then mimosa
instant reviving three people at once
was pretty disappointing not gonna lie i
really hope that noel's reversion to
tsundere will be temporary and that she
will eventually summon the courage to
tell austin the truth just like gaia did
with loro i also hope that mimosa's
power will have strict limitations and
that she won't be able to just instantly
revive anyone who gets injured during
this showdown because if she can do that
then why even worry about the outcome if
mimosa can really do this and there are
no major limitations on her power then
we already know that good guys are gonna
crush it the bad guys are gonna lose and
every even remotely relevant character
is going to survive in terms of black
clover story developments that i didn't
like this is right up there with
everyone instantly forgiving poetry for
all the horrible things that he had done
for years and then pawtry suddenly going
from one of the main villains of an
entire saga to a good guy elf and i
won't even get into the whole julius
controversy because then we'd be here
all day instead of getting into it i'll
turn it over to you guys let me know
down in the comments what you thought
about this chapter including noel
reverting back to a violent tsundere and
mimosa becoming shenron from dbz can
tabata still find a way to make this
final showdown intense and suspenseful
even after this instant mass reviving
that we just witnessed or was this a
step too far let me know down below if
you enjoyed this black lover video and
you want to see more in the future just
leave that like it only takes a second
but it helps a lot and if you enjoy our
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications don't forget that you
really have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says all if
you don't do that you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to alpha
sigma he is an absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algital hinokamien water the toasted chi
the spike dylan issador spidey life
chanel tungsten tarcus big buddhist and
monkey d quilly finally thank you to all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel crews ratheora very
gucci alicia actor bonnie parks joanne
garcia ted no ted fat boy games corey
mcgowan and soul ray slice and dice if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patreon exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you